ارقام عده حققها المغرب بعد فوزه على
المنتخب البلجيكي في مونديال قطر المغرب
سجل فوزه الثالث في تاريخ المشاركاته في
كاس العالم حيث فاز على البرتغال في
مونديال الارجنتين وانتصر على اسكتلندا في
مونديال فرنسا لاول مره في تاريخ العرب
يسجل بديلا في مباراه واحده في كاس العالم
بعد هدفي عبد الصمد الصابري وزكريا بوخلال
طيب لاسود الاطلس الذين حافظوا على
شباكههم نظيفه في مبارتين متتاليتين اول
مره منذ مونديال الارجنتين وحينها تفضل
المغرب مجموعته وتاهل للدوري الثاني اما
المنتخب البلجيكي فكانت خسارته مع المغرب
ثاني خساره له من المنتخبات العربيه بعد
خساره الاولى امام المنتخب السعودي في
مونديال الولايات المتحده